steam and mud billowing from a still
active volcano or preventing recovery
crews from getting to a New Zealand
Island where a sudden eruption hit
dozens of tourists the number of people
missing and presumed dead after Monday's
eruption is now up to nine at this hour
the confirmed death toll at six Ramey
Inocencio and FACA Thani New Zealand has
more on the story
two days after erupting white island
remains a deathtrap this morning an
increase in seismic activity made it too
dangerous to dispatch recovery crews we
all agree that retrieving bodies of the
deceased from the island is an absolute
imperative every day that passes with
those bodies unrecovered is a day of
anguish for the loved ones who have been
affected at least 30 people are being
treated in hospitals across the country
pushing burn units to capacity with
supplies being flown in from places
including the United States this is just
the start of a very long process that
for some patients will last several
months a five-mile exclusion zone has
been set up all around white island that
means neither boats nor planes are
allowed and it's not just a legal
regulation its cultural too many people
here are members of New Zealand's
indigenous Maori potahto gato poll is
one of their leaders we have a living
breathing volcana she is life she does
breathe she exists the whole domain of
going into where she is there's always
going to be a risk factor and earlier
today a volcanologist with New Zealand's
Geoscience agency told us there's still
a 40 to 60% chance of yet a second
eruption happening in the next 24 hours
residents here are already dealing with
frayed nerves and freight emotions for
CBS this morning
ramie Inocencio [ __ ] on e New Zealand